what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really exciting
news about Spider-Man 4. it's been a
while since we've really heard anything
about Spider-Man 4 but the MCU right now
seems to be quite busy and it does seem
like some of their slate release dates
are going to be changing but in the
midst of all of that rumors suggests
that it's going to be releasing in July
of
2024. this of course gives Spider-Man
one more movie before we go into the
Avengers the King Dynasty and the
Avengers Secret Wars witch Spider-Man
does indeed need to come out before
those films and we know that secret Wars
is going to be a huge multiversal film
with tons of different Heroes and teams
yes we'll have the Avengers but we're
also going to have the Fantastic Four
also we're going to have the X-Men and
it looks like we are going to possibly
get the Defenders as well now ever since
Charlie Cox made his return as Matt
Murdock AKA Daredevil and the MCU and
Spider-Man no way home and then of
course in She-Hulk all of the fans of
the Netflix Marvel series have been
given a great deal of hope hope that
other characters can now return like The
Punisher Iron Fist Luke Cage Jessica
Jones and anybody else from that
Universe well of course with Avengers
Secret Wars being about other universes
that makes it extremely possible however
it does look like we're actually going
to be seeing these characters in our
main Universe in the MCU in Earth 616
and it looks like a lot of them could be
making a debut in Spider-Man 4. and this
could lead up to what could quite
possibly be one of the best Spider-Man
stories yet the MCU we have a recent
report from The Insider account The
Watcher on Twitter and they stated
recently that Spider-Man 4 will feature
Peter meeting his street level peers Now
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios has already said that he wants
Spider-Man and Daredevil to team up
specifically on the street level of
things and since Peter already met Matt
doc this just makes the most sense
although right now Matt Murdock would
not know who Peter Parker was behold
Doctor Strange spelling doll but I'm
sure Daredevil knows who Spider-Man is
and in fact since Daredevil mentioned
Hell's Kitchen I'm sure that he knows
the other Defenders as well and I'm sure
the other Defenders have heard about
Spider-Man however we don't know if
Spider-Man has heard of them yet but if
he hasn't he is about to Spider-Man no
way home left us at the end of the movie
seeing Peter on that street level like
the Spider-Man that we've kind of been
waiting for he monitors the radio for a
crime then when he hears it he goes out
and he fights it this is a street-level
Spider-Man this isn't Spider-Man in
space with the Avengers not that we
didn't love that because we did but this
is a more grounded Spider-Man one who is
going to meet other grounded superheroes
and it looks like that is happening in
Spider-Man 4 and I would expect to see
several different characters appear Matt
Murdoch slash Daredevil for sure but
recently we've gotten news from another
Insider my time to to shine hello that
Jessica Jones will be coming to the MCU
there's also been big rumors that Jon
bernthal's The Punisher is going to be
coming to the MCU as well I'm expecting
most of these old Defender characters to
return rumor has it that we'll see some
of them in the Echo series and the
Daredevil series and whichever ones we
do see I think we could probably see in
Spider-Man 4 which will probably lead to
the street level Avengers team be
informed now this is good but also bad
news so before we jump in what this is
all building up to in the villain let's
talk about the bad news the bad news is
a lot of us really do want to see Peter
Parker truly on his own just one
Spider-Man fighting one villain with no
help now right now it's set up to be
that way nobody knows who Peter Parker
is not even MJ not Ned not happy nobody
and even though people still know who
Spider-Man is any relationship with
Peter Parker that anybody might have had
is gone so the bad news is is that if we
get all of these characters in the neck
X film he won't exactly be on his own
which is something that a lot of people
want to see especially because it's set
up perfectly but there is of course
still hope and rumor has it that Tom
Holland has signed a new contract with
Marvel Studios for six more Spider-Man
appearances now we know that Spider-Man
4 is going to be one of them Spider-Man
5 and Spider-Man 6 should be another two
and then of course Avengers the King
Dynasty and Secret Wars and then he'll
most likely make a cameo in Echo or
Daredevil or another series but the good
news about that is there should be three
new Spider-Man films within the next
handful of years Spider-Man 4 5 and 6.
so there is room for him to have a movie
that is truly just him and I for one
hope it plays out like this in
Spider-Man 4 he meets these characters
like Daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage
he meets them and he fights with them in
some minor scenes not in the big final
fight scene but some scenes that happen
randomly throughout the movie he meets
these other Heroes and realizes that
that there is a street level team out
there there are street level heroes
fighting crime and in the movie they let
him know that if he ever needs any help
they're there for him because I'm sure
in Spider-Man 4 he's going to express to
somebody that he literally has no one so
hopefully he meets The Defenders and
they say hey if you ever need us give us
a call we get some few fight scenes and
then they depart before the final fight
that gives us awesome cameos but then it
also gives us Spider-Man on his own
still but then in future movies they can
come together again to fight Kingpin
right now Kingpin is being set up in the
MCU as a big villain we saw him in
Hawkeye he is going to be the main
villain of the echo series and he's also
going to be the main villain of the
Daredevil Series so he is a villain for
a lot of different projects but he is
also a classic iconic Spider-Man villain
one who we want to see him fight in the
MCU well good news is it looks like
Marvel Studios is setting that up and it
looks like they are setting it up to
where Spider-Man and is going to team up
with the Defenders to take down Kingpin
Kingpin is going to have what seems to
be a pretty good story in the MCU going
through Hawkeye to the Daredevil series
and since Spider-Man is supposed to meet
his street level peers in Spider-Man 4
and a team up as expected it would make
sense that they all team up to take down
Kingpin because we know that one of
these Spider-Man movies should be based
off of what Marvel Studios has teased us
with a Venom movie the Venom symbiote
now exists inside of the MCU although
it's not Tom Hardy's Venom the Symbiote
is there according to some rumors Tom
Holland Spider-Man is going to get the
Symbiote in Avengers Secret Wars much
like he does for the very first time in
the comics but the only movie happening
before Secret Wars is Spider-Man 4 so
Spider-Man 5 could be about Spider-Man
and the Venom symbiote or they could
push that back to Spider-Man 6 however
since Spider-Man 5 is going to happen
pretty much right after Secret Wars
Spider-Man 5 might be the Venom film and
then Spider-Man 6 might be this big team
up film with the street level Avengers
slash The Defenders going up against
Kingpin and possibly even more villains
possibly a Sinister Six team which I
think both would be kind of cool it
would be cool to see a bunch of
different Heroes take on one Villain
Like Kingpin but it would also be kind
of cool to see a bunch of different
Heroes take on the Sinister Six so they
each are fighting one person either way
it looks like we are about to see a
different side of the MCU aside that is
more of a crime side the street level
crime with ganks and the tracksuit Mafia
which we saw in the Echo series
basically a big and huge crime
organization ran by Kingpin and I for
one am extremely excited to see how this
all plays out in the MCU but let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
how would you like to see Spider-Man
team up with the Defenders and go up
against Kingpin let us know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the latest MCU news don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
foreign